just like a movie you just like a song
yeah yeah brother [ __ ] yo dawg
I'm here baby hey hey yo yo man I'm no
longer be Li in this house who you are
yo you know you heard about the wolf
King what's the whoa k you've heard
about the okay yeah everyone knows about
the locals right I mean right no I woke
you are I'm slept King oh [ __ ] I don't
know if you know this or not but I am
the slept King I'll tell you why I don't
know what's going on
I'm not awakened to or aware what's
going on and yet I know everything all
right I don't I sleep I don't know
anything yet slept King is somebody who
is not aware of anything but has the
most to say that's why that's I don't
like the way you said it
yeah I don't want to sound ignant all
right no I am the slub King and um
listen guys I was in Dallas and I've
been on the road and I just wanted to
sit say what's out to my peeps in Dallas
you know I never done well in that room
I didn't play that room in four years
and I you know I decided to try and yeah
man it was good so that a couple of them
three of them whoa um it's all because
of TV fans bro they come out they came
out and supported and I want to let TB
fans know that um if you come on a
Saturday I'm not gonna come out you know
people are like they tweet come out to
take photos or whatever I only do that
[ __ ] on Sundays the last day I'll tell
you why because if I go out on a
Saturday you have people that aren't TV
fans and they're drunk big white people
and they'll grab me they'll pick me up
on my shirt and lift me up and go hey
man you were funny you know I don't like
that and people get drunk and they
manhandle me and I'm small and frail
like I'm
[ __ ] king you know looking you know my
muscles are developed let him sleep
nicely my muscles haven't been developed
it's like I've been up in a coma he
needs eight naps a day
I need a naps a day so when people
manhandled me like that I get scared you
know so on Sundays if you come then I
always go up because only one show and I
give everyone hugs and fondle and dude I
sorta got mondo I don't know I fondle
people but dude I wanted to say this
Sunday um this guy gave me a DVD it's a
my back I gotta grab it because he wrote
me a letter and I wrote it and I and I
read it in front of um the audience I
nearly broke up it broke me up I'll grab
it also um and I wasn't in Dallas for
reasons I cannot explain on air but can
we not call ourselves TB cuz that's
short fernlet universally that's
tuberculosis I've know we had like a
whole conversation of others we first
started a podcast just make sure we
never said TV or not one reason tgd be
like something but TB cuz I don't want
to be associated to the Giardia WA okay
Bobbi has a DVD so this guy so this guy
is this kid he wasn't he look nerdy look
skinny he kind of look like a meth head
I'll be honest but I mean but I look in
his eyes there's softness inside a soul
I can read that as slop King and so I'm
on stage and he goes hey I brought you
this DVD which is one of my favorite
movies all time he put stroll and roll -
[ __ ] troll - Hills right may borrow them
yeah and he wrote me this can I read it
yeah this I read this to the audience
okay
mmm Bobby thank you for being an
inspiration from one former addict to
another Thanks everything you've been
through and overcome makes me want to be
a better person you rock you taught me
that it's okay to be weird and to
embrace it
Ryan Russell yeah that's so sweet okay
damn that's okay all day what's SK slept
game yeah okay
how can how can you how can you okay I
mean it's like it's it's getting so real
it's too real is this to cheer horn up
no it's not to tease I'm not ruining my
[ __ ] horn I know I'm not tuning my
horn and that's rude that you would even
accuse me of that what I'm doing is you
know let me say something right now okay
look at my finger right now okay look at
my finger right now do you see my finger
yes
what you don't see is God's finger
touching my finger like this that's what
you don't this is what you don't see
okay so I don't know if that's bragging
but that's where I'm at as a vessel for
the Lord Wow Tex